other news tonight Metro Police
revealing new video and details in its
investigation into the murder of
journalist Jeff Garman and for the first
time we are seeing footage of the
suspect and the car that he or she was
driving Vanessa Murphy has the latest
from Metro
to a series of burglaries in his
neighborhood in the meantime Metro
Police are asking for the Public's help
they're saying this is the suspect
they're asking viewers to pay attention
to the walk the clothing they're also
searching for this vehicle believed to
be a red GMC Yukon this investigation
began Saturday morning after review
journal investigative reporter Jeff
gearman was found stabbed to death
outside his Northwest Valley Home Metro
Police say he was killed Friday morning
though Captain Dory Koren says there has
been a series of burglaries with a
suspect also wearing construction type
clothing but he is also saying police
believe this is an isolated incident and
the public is not in danger I asked why
I we still stand by the idea that it is
an isolated incident there's nothing
that's an absolute in our business
unfortunately and we are exploring all
possibilities uh in this investigation
due to the nature of gearman's work
Metro has enacted the major case
protocol meaning more resources are
dedicated to this case but again a
motive is still not yet known Vanessa
Murphy 8 News Now